[Müzik]
baktığımız zaman insan kendine var
olduğu zamandan mektebine sorular
sormuştu ve bilmemek bu sorulara cevap
bulamadım açmaz ise bu Az önce
bahsettiğim durumun süregelme halidir
herkesin Merhabalar ben Can Harun Bugün
sizlerle beraber İnsanlığın en eski
şarkımızı arttırma
konuşacak Öncelikle insan Aşkımız nedir
Az önce bahsettiğim gibi açmazlar
insanın kendini sorduğu soruları
cevaplamama halini süre gelmesi
ve bildiğiniz üzere insanlar varlığını
yüzyıllarda Hatta binlerce yıldır
sürdüren bir varlıktır
Peki bir soruyla devam edelim
Sizce
tarih boyunca sorduğu sorular da cevap
bulamadığı en eski soru nedir
Bakın şimdi nasıl ve neden yandığını
Hayır
ya da evet gökyüzündeki suyun yeryüzüne
nasıl ulaşırım
ya da tekerleğin nasıl yuvarlandığını
ekolojik dengenin nasıl ilerlediğimi Ya
da bilgisayar olduğunu nasıl üreteyim
Hayır
İnsanoğlu günümüze kadar ki zamanda
bunların Hepsine cevap bulmayı
başarabilmiştir ancak bir soru var ki
hiçbir şekilde cevap bulamamıştı
evreni ve düzenin nasıl bir kim
tarafından varıldım Evet
Kimileri evren ve düzenin birileri
tarafından var olduğunu Kimileri doğanın
ve evrenin kendi gücü doğrultusunda var
olduğunu kimi kimileri ise bunun bir
bilinmezlik olduğu kanaatindedir
ve biz Aslında bu tür şeylere inanç
başlığı altında inceledi
insanlar Farklı boyutlarda İnanır veya
İnanmaz kimlerin bu var olan evlenme
düzeni bir kişi tarafından Daha doğrusu
biri varlık tarafından oluşuyor Kimileri
varlıklar tarafından oluşuyor ve
Kimileri doğanın ve evlenelim kendi gücü
tarafından mı oluşturduğuna İnanır
kimileri ise bunun kalıcı bir bilim
mantıklı olduğunu söylemiştik
gelin İsterseniz inanç başlarına
birazcık inceleyelim
Öncelikle inanmamak lazım Evet inanma
[Müzik]
diğer bir yandan Az önce bahsettiğim
gibi bilinmezlikler akrostişisin başlığı
altında aklınızda varlığını veya
yokluğunu kesinlikle bilinmezlik olarak
da yani bu konu hakkında bir yorum
yapılamayacağını soruyor
aslında bir tanrının var olduğunu
savunuyorum Ancak bunun hakkında bir
kanıt olmadığını söyledi ya da agresif
deizmin tam zıttı agnostik ateistinden
bahsedebiliriz agnostik Ateizm ise bir
tanrının var olmadığını Ancak bunun da
ispatlanamayacağını soruyor veya zayıf
akması bizim bu bahsettiğim şey ise bir
Tanrım varinin henüz ve şu an bir
bilinebileceği yani anlık olarak gördüm
ben ve gelelim bizim konuşmamızın ana
hatlarını verebilecek olan günah Evet
inanmak bir Tanrıya yüce bir varlığa
veya Yüce varlıklara inanmaktır yani var
olan düzen ve evrenin bir şey tarafından
çıktı tesadüfen
şimdi konuşmamızın ana tezini birazcık
daha açıklamak için gelin
inanç tariflerini içeriyor
ilkelinerler
insanoğlu bu var olduğunda koca bir doğa
ile baş başa kendisi doğaya zarar
fiziksel olarak çok zayıf bir durumda ve
kendisi İnsanoğlu o haliyle kendisinden
fiziksel olarak üstünüz şeyleri kendine
bir yaratıcı veya kutsal bir varlık
olarak belirtilmiştir Çünkü insanın
elinde olan o dönemdeki tek şey fiziksel
Üstün
lüklü İnsanoğlu başta kendini yakan ve
ormanları kası vuran Ateşlere tapmıştır
ardından ateşleri yaratan yıldırımlara
ya da Daha sonrasında havayı kapkara
bulutlar ve kaplayan ve her yeri ateşten
saçına volkanlara
duaların tanrının bir temsilcisi olarak
kabul etmişti yani animalizm ortaya
çıkmış
tı ya da bunun sonrasında insanoğlu bu
tatlı varlıkları ve bu tatlı hayvanların
kendince totemlerini yaparak totemimiz
mi ortaya çıkartmıştır
Yani bu dönemi ufak bir şekilde
özetleyecek olursak İnsanoğlu elinde
olan fiziksel üstünlüğü tamir edilmemiş
Yıllar yıllar geçti İnsanoğlu geliştiği
okuduğu yazdığı çizdi bir şeyler yaptı
ve değişen insanoğlu ile beraber
inançlar da değişti insanoğlu bu uzun
süreçte bazı şeyleri rasyonalize etmeye
başardı Örneğin eşsizlik ve bilgi
İnsanoğlu fark etti ki bir şeyin ne
kadar Ender ne kadar eşsiz ve ne kadar
tekse o kadar kutsal ve o kadar Özeldir
ve bunun doğrultusunda İnsanoğlu tek
tanrı şunu almayı tercih ettim
yine başla görüş
Se
ne kadar çoksa ne kadar kalabalıksa ve
ne kadar fazlaysa o kadar fazla eş gibi
oldunuz ve İnsanoğlu Çok tanrılı dinlere
inanıyor Bu sayede
Daha sonrasında İnsanoğlu tanrının
kendisiyle iletişime geçtiğime inandı
çağrının kendisine işaretler Yollarında
tanrının kendisine bir şeylere inanması
için birilerini görevlendirdiğini
[Müzik]
her dönem farklı bir şekilde
yorumlamıştı bu dinler ilk ortaya
çıktığında insanoğlu bu dinlere ilk
inanmaya başladığı zamanlarda
hayatlarında çok fazla bir şey olmadığı
için hayatlarının merkezine bu dinleri
koydular çevre coğrafyalarına bu dinleri
yaymaya çalıştılar ve insanların bu
dinleri dayattılar
ardından süreler geçtiği 17 yüzyıl 18
yüzyıl ve İnsanoğlu maddiyatla tanıştık
yüksek tanıştık somut unsurlarına daha
fazla değer vermeye başladı YouTube
kullanarak
bu unsurlara daha rahat eleştirebiliyor
İnsanoğlu hayatındaki emellerine ulaşmak
için dinleri kullandı ancak tabi ki bir
topluluğa doğru uyandırmak için
kendisine bahane olarak bunların hepsini
dinler acaba bunda yaptığını da yaptı ve
girmemize baktığımız zaman da binler
bireyselleştirildi artık dayanma gibi
bir şey yok
hayatlarımızda onca fazla konuşulurken
başarı hırs Aşk Hüzün bir sürü Duygu
içerisinde dinlenen bireysel bir şey
yapıyorlar patlamaktadır ve esprisi
kadar Dominant bir durumda değildi
rahatlıkla
konuşmaların
kısımlarında elle olan sahip olduğumuz
gibi kelimeler kullandım Bunun sebebi
kalitesiz bir dil kullanmam değil de
İki elini aşağıda insanların elinde
fiziksel gücüm olduğundan bahsettim ve
fiziksel gücü önem verdiklerinden
bahsettim değişen insanoğlu ile beraber
insanların elinde olan yeni rasyonalize
edilenlerle beraber farklı şeylere
inandıran
Ve bu üç büyüklüğünden bahsettiğim yerde
ise insanoğlunun tanrının varlığına dair
yeni kanıtlar yeni duyumlar elde
ettiğimden bahsetti
buradan çıkaracağımız sonuç şu
İnsanoğlu var olduğu Dönemin en başından
beri evinde olanlar doğrultusunda
inanmıştır her dönem elinde ne varsa onu
doğrultusunu yememesi
İnsanoğlu elinde olanları ya da sahip
olduklarının ötesine çıkıp bir inanç
benim Sevmemiştir her dönem elinde olan
farklı şeyleri farklı şekillerde
yorumlamışlardır bazen farklı Tanrılar
bazen aynı Tanrıların farklı şekilde
satma falan bazen Hepsi farklı tanrılara
farklı bir şekilde
ve bir soruyla
yapmak istiyorum
biliyorsunuz Yüzyıllar boyunca inançlar
değişti inanışlar değişti İnsanların
görüşleri değişti Peki bundan 50 veya
100 yıl sonra sizin inandığınız şeyler
değişirse inandığınız Tanrı veya değil
hala aynı kalacak mıdır
teşekkür ederim